human beings naturally live inside of a
circle and that circle is this is what
you're supposed to think in your culture
this is how you're supposed to behave
there are rules and that circle
existed in ancient egypt it didn't have
the same
things that we have but it still was a
limitation you're not supposed to think
this an ancient egypt you're supposed to
behave this way the moment you praise
limits for the human being they're
fascinated by what lies beyond it's part
of our nature we like what's supposedly
transgressive we're not supposed to go
there we want to go there i'm saying
that what lies outside that circle is
what i call the realm of the sublime and
i want people to begin to think outside
of that to expand their minds to expand
their consciousness to not live in the
sort of narrow little world of your
smartphone of what people are telling
you how you're supposed to think and
feel but to expand your mind to other
possibilities of looking at the world
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
thank you very much for joining today is
an absolutely brilliant mind on the show
his name is robert greene he's an author
he's written some amazing books he's
written the 48 laws of power the art of
seduction 33 strategies of war 50th law
mastery laws of human nature and the
book that i read every morning right now
is called the daily laws which is
more bite size right so it's a couple
paragraphs and then there'll be some
lesson at the bottom and something
contemplative so for me it's a really
insightful
book to flip through in the morning and
read each day because there's you know
for every day there's a lesson i mean in
this episode what you hear is just a
contemplative brilliant mind we talked
about
the universe the big bang we got a
little into you know extraterrestrial of
course i have to throw that in you know
and we talked about his stroke as well
and the effect that his stroke three
years ago has had on his life you know
what you're just gonna have to listen
it's totally worth it hang in there it's
a just a beautiful a beautiful outlook
of life and so many so many lessons
please hit the subscribe button if you
like this podcast and you want to keep
listening to it and you want
notifications everybody's good at
something
and it's kind of just about figuring out
or do you disagree
no i agree but i'm only good at one
thing
what is your definition of the one thing
well it's just writing i can't like sing
i'm totally tone deaf my dancing sucks
i wanted to be a basketball player and i
can't make a shot my life depends on it
all i can do is write so there you go
well i would say that if yes clearly you
can write but i would also say that if
you can write you're also
um
intellectual you're a thinker
you
like to philosophize you're
contemplative like you're i would say
there's got like i'm sure that you're
probably well read on your own
so
you know maybe the expression of all of
that collected energy comes out in books
but look we're we're all grateful for
that
well that's a very nice way of putting
it thank you that makes it seem more
flattering than what i meant but okay
speaking of books i have your daily laws
but i love it it's part of my morning
routine every day i read i read the uh i
read the
we call it advice the the
um okay well then maybe let's start with
that i actually was really curious what
your
relationship or
definition is of law because it's a
common word you obviously use with your
books and the titles
well it's a bit of a literary device
it's not like the law of nature it's not
like einstein's law of relativity so get
that out of the way it's more kind of
i'm trying to give you a sense that
these are things that have deep history
behind them which is why i do a lot of
research for my books
so when i wrote my first book the 48
laws of power
which sort of set the tone for all of my
books i read like three four hundred
books to do the research i wanted to
give the reader a sense that these are
timeless aspects of power that transcend
your culture that transcend your period
of time that they're equally valid for
ancient china as they are for 21st
century america
so that kind of breadth i mean i know
it's ambitious maybe it's even a bit
pretentious but that kind of ambition
i want to sort of say this is a law it's
almost like a law of relativity so
law number one in the 48 laws of power
is never outshine the master
if you violate that law if you're in
your in your work somehow you make
yourself appear better than the person
above you they are going to naturally
feel insecure their ego will be
triggered now maybe there are a few
saints out there like a gandhi whom that
might not happen to but it will happen
to 98 of the people that this that that
are in the situation and so with that
kind of of logic behind in that kind of
history i think it kind of is something
that i could say is a law
why
i i know you talk about that a lot
there's a lot around mentors and and
people like that and it's not about
outshining and it's also not about what
you can get from them a lot of times
it's having a relationship with what you
can offer them and allowing them to
shine
expand on that like would you have
experience with that directly that uh
initiated that especially to be the
first law
what's this what's the history of that
with you you know i had um i once
counted with my girlfriend i've had like
60 different jobs in my life prior to
riding the 48 laws of power and i've
seen every kind of power situation and
maybe about three times in my life i've
actually violated law number one and
they paid a very heavy price for it so
for instance i was
a researcher on a television show i'm
not going to name tell you the name of
that show because it's a little bit
embarrassing but i was a researcher on
the show
and your job was to find stories that
would end up being produced for this
program
and i was by far the best researcher
there i was getting like 90 of the
stories even though there was a team of
like six or seven researchers
and um and then suddenly i found myself
being fired
what you know what was going on
and i was kind of clashing a little bit
with my superior because she thought i
had a bit of an attitude and i really
didn't have an attitude i just maybe i'm
a little bit cocky i agree but basically
i had out shown the master i had made
her as a woman in this instance feel
insecure like maybe the people in the in
the company thought that i was better
than her or that i could
take over her job which wasn't my intent
anyway but i got fired and nobody tells
you when you're fired for that
that you inadvertently tripped up this
person's ego because nobody likes to
admit that you're fired for other
reasons you had an attitude you didn't
show up on time blah blah blah blah blah
the truth is it was about ego right you
had outshone the master and when you
don't know why you're fired it's very
painful it was very painful to me it was
very emotional and slowly i kind of
figured it out but it happened in other
times as well because
i i thought i always thought when you go
to work it's about the quality of the
work that matters not about what how
people feel themselves whether they feel
secure about their position or not i
thought it was just about getting
results but that's not the case
so it's law number one because i have
had so many people tell me about very
painful stories in their life where the
same thing has happened a lot of
musicians very famous people in the rap
industry because i have a lot of rappers
who who who are fans of my books
athletes etc it's an incredibly common
theme it goes back to the bible it goes
back thousands of years so it's part of
human nature and that's why i made it
law number one
what do you do if
you're
what do you do if you're you going back
to that point in time where you
were
it sounds like overqualified for the
position um
or uh exceeding uh all the other talent
including the boss what do you do in
that scenario well that's a great
question and that's what i talk about in
in the book so you have to be careful
you have to be aware of this so i tell
people you assume that the person above
you your boss and we all have bosses no
matter if you're the president of the
united states
you assume that this person
because they reach this position they
don't have insecurities they must be
very powerful and very confident because
that's what goes with being a leader but
it's actually the opposite the higher up
you go the more insecure you become you
don't think that people are are giving
you the respect that you deserve you're
extremely attuned to how people are
judging you or looking at you right
and
so you inadvertently trip up their
insecurities by assuming that they don't
have any insecurities right so the first
thing is to be aware that it's a human
being that is your boss it's not like
some machine and they're just like any
other human being they have an ego they
have insecurities they have all these
other kind of flaws in their character
so first be aware of that and then
find ways to kind of defuse it perhaps
in that situation with that woman i
could have been less cocky i could have
been a little less arrogant i could have
said you know i didn't really find these
stories you know i really it's your help
and you're mentoring me that led me to
them there were ways to give them credit
so you kind of defuse it doesn't mean
that i have to start doing a bad job i
never advocate that
but there are always ways to make the
other person feel secure about them
sometimes that might involve a little
bit of a white lie but sometimes it's
the truth you know she did help me at
one point she did she'd give me some
good advice i could have done handled
the situation better i want you to get
people out of the idea that it's always
the other person that's to blame for the
problems that happen in your life
you are often responsible for things
that happen like i was responsible in
that situation and if you look at it
that way and you go
what did i do in that situation that was
wrong what can i correct that gives you
power
if you assume oh she was just evil she
was just you know something's wrong with
her then i just have no power in that
situation i'm just a victim but i can
see what i did that was wrong suddenly i
can correct that
have you ever had that happen to you
yeah not probably in a job i have had
quite a unique sort of job trajectory i
sort of self-employed but also like
i was kind of always the point person
being a race car driver like it was up
to me to be taking charge
some people resent your success and
think that you hadn't earned it that you
that you were kind of outshining some of
the yeah actually that probably was the
case early on in my indycar career
people were a little bit offended with
all the attention and yeah um and so
i've also probably experienced it the
other way where someone comes in and
they try to sort of like
out cool you or outshine you in some way
and you're like look back and down kid
yeah exactly um so yeah i think that's
putting thought to it yeah you're right
that is a common experience but i think
that the thing that you said right at
the end that is something that i think
we should talk about is this
blame game that we play all the time uh
or most of the time and most people and
i'm totally guilty of it i'm sure
everybody is at least
on a regular basis until there becomes
some sort of like shift or
awakening within you that wow everywhere
i go with problems there i am um so
what is it that makes us
like that why do we blame people why do
we
why i mean i think about attitude that's
a lot of the you know you talk about
attitude a lot what um what is the what
is the source of that blame game we play
in our lives
well it goes very deep into human nature
right because the feeling that um i am
to blame causes all kinds of
self-reflections like what is what is it
about me that's wrong is there something
essentially wrong with me
so it's much easier to focus outward
we're not designed by the way our brains
are are created or wired which is
something i'm going into for my next
book we're not wired to reflect on
ourselves to reflect on the brain itself
to reflect on our own functioning to
reflect on our own emotions
if you study neuroscience our emotions
are actually disguised from us we don't
see the source of them we may see the
source of a thought
sometimes but we never see the source of
our emotions like where does my anger
really come from so instead of focusing
inward on my anger really comes
from something in my childhood or from
something that happened a couple days
ago somebody said something we're going
to focus on the thing in front of us
that person said something they made me
angry they made me angry not i'm feeling
the anger right so we're wired to
continually look outward and see other
people as responsible for it and so
i wrote a book called the laws of human
nature which is my sixth book
and it's kind of long it's you know i
hate to say it's like 160 pages long i
don't want to discourage people from
reading it but i'm being honest
but i have like 18
laws in there about human nature and the
kind of negative qualities that we all
can have
narcissism
irrationality
envy grandiosity aggression on and on
and on and the point that i make in the
book is
our tendency as human beings is to
always think that the other person has
these qualities
they're a narcissist right she's full of
envy he's aggressive but we never go
maybe i'm a narcissist maybe i have
narcissistic tendencies right
and i make the point in the book
that you are a human being that you were
born with the same brain that everybody
else is born with there are very few
differences between one human to another
in the brain functioning
and so to assume that you aren't
narcissistic is absurd it's wired into
our nature to be self-absorbed we're all
self-absorbed including myself and when
i wrote the book it was kind of painful
for me to realize
robert you actually are quite
narcissistic
but it's not natural for us to think
that way we want to always want to point
fingers at other people because that's
so much easier and we're creatures that
like the easy way out
i
have a theory and that's
human nature is to do the minimum
and
everyone's minimum's different you know
my dad was pretty tough on me and you
know my minimum was different than
someone else who maybe didn't get
grounded for something and you know but
human nature is to do the minimum which
is why i feel like you see like you know
second and third generation kids within
wealthy families like the minimum gets
pretty low like there's a lot there's
you don't have to make make it yourself
there's a fallback this is definitely
part of the human condition to
um
to uh
deflect and and protect ourselves like i
think that's kind of
you know the ego coming in again to
negate against pain
um
are you saying that there's
an aspect of narcissism within everyone
an aspect of a monster within everyone
an aspect of jealousy are you saying all
we hold all of these aspects it's just
what we put our
what makes what makes someone have more
narcissism or more anger or more
kindness what makes that pie get broken
up differently
well the i maintain well first of all
some narcissism there is a genetic
element to that no doubt and there's
also an element of early rearing right
your attachment theories how your
parents related to you so there is kind
of a background i'm not saying that
everyone's equally a narcissist there
are clearly what i call
deep narcissists and i have a kind of a
kind of an image that i've created
or let's say there's a at the high point
you are completely empathetic you can
get outside of yourself and think
completely of another person be as kind
i can get inside your mind and at the
bottom point at zero you were completely
100 absorbed in yourself right
most of us are at that kind of 50 line
right
and
if we get if painful things happen and
we're upset we can kind of dip below
that and become more self-absorbed
if we're happy and we're in a good mood
and we're in a relationship and things
are clicking we can get out of that and
rise up to 70 maybe 80 percent
some people
from very early age are locked into like
that 20 or 30
percentage position
because
they had parents who abandoned them who
didn't give them the proper attention
etc or they had parents who suffocated
them they didn't have this uh the
ability or the space to create a solid
sense of self
so when we're when we have experienced
some kind of painful situation
the first thing is we retreat inward
right that's our first instinct and we
want to protect ourselves right but if
you have no sense of self to retreat
into if it's kind of all fragmented and
you don't feel like there is anything
solid there you're gonna your natural
instinct is to get angry people to find
fault with them to attack them to go
into what's called narcissistic rage etc
so
some people are at that lower point and
other people are higher in that case a
lot of it has to do
with childhood early childhood but the
key the point that i make in the book
that applies to all of the things you
mentioned all the laws is
your degree of self-awareness
so if you delude yourself and say no
i'm the one person on the planet that's
not a narcissist i'm the only person
ever created who doesn't have any of
these tendencies you can't correct
yourself right
you'll be at that position you'll be
locked through your whole life or you'll
keep dipping down
so the key is
no
i have these tendencies i'm not a deep
narcissist like some of the people we
see in our own culture who are like that
right
okay but i have these tendencies i'm
aware of them now now i can begin to
catch them i can begin to see
in a conversation i'm not really
listening to the other person i'm
hearing my own thoughts i'm absorbed in
my own head right
so you need awareness
envy is an emotion that nobody wants to
admit to because it's a very ugly
admission it means i feel inferior to
you therefore i envy you
okay
but envy is so natural we all feel it i
feel it 100 times during the course of
the day i tell people
somebody you know ryan holiday very well
my former men
yes okay thank you
my former mentee
you know he's
becoming more successful than i ever was
you know he's outshining the master and
yes at moments i will feel envy for his
youth for his success for his family etc
but i'm aware of it and therefore my
awareness gives me the power to say
robert that envy is an ugly emotion you
don't want to feel it let's change it
into something else
so i i hope i'm answering your question
i think okay i think it leads to the
next good question which
i think is
challenging
how the question is how do we
create awareness of ourselves
and i think it's tricky because first
off people don't even know to to even
want awareness like i think people can
generalize and say that like um yeah i'm
aware like i mean i went to work and
this guy was a jerk and then i came you
know and like food was dick cold and i
don't know whatever i'm just making up a
story but i don't think anyone would not
it's almost like being healthy i feel
like everyone could say like yeah i want
to be healthy but nobody really knows
not everyone knows how to do it
and i feel like awareness is similar in
the sense that i think people want
awareness but i don't know if they know
how to get it
well it's what you said earlier where we
want the easy path i call it the line of
least resistance we take the line of
least resistance
so
if we weren't aware that exercise can
actually make us feel better and get us
healthier when we go to the gym we would
just do the little the tiniest little
bit of movement and then go home and
have a beer and think wow we exercise
today but we're aware that you have to
do more of it
that you have to build up your muscles
that over the period of weeks and months
of going to the gym of lifting weights
of swimming and running you're going to
build up straight and it's going to get
better and better and better okay
awareness is a muscle
it's not literally a muscle it's a
mental muscle let's just use an image
here right
so if you just go yeah i'm aware okay
enough story over
it's never going to happen it's like
going to the gym you have to practice it
every day you have to have it has to
become a habit all right so that's the
first thing for you just to get down on
your hands and knees and go
i am not aware of myself
i am deluding myself in most situations
it's a come to jesus moment you admit
that you are not aware that you're not
practicing this okay now you can go to
the next step
and then and i tell you tell this like a
lot in the daily laws but in all of my
books it's a process there are baby
steps that you go along the way
and the hardest thing for people is to
detach themselves from themselves and
that's the main power i'm trying to give
you in my books the ability to look at
yourself with some distance and
detachment and observe yourself in
action
so you begin
by let's say tomorrow we're going to
start this process i heard robert and
i'm going to start it tomorrow okay
i want you just one time during the day
to catch yourself feeling an emotion
right
anger envy love excitement whatever it
is
and to step back
and just for a couple of minutes to try
and analyze that emotion and go where
does it really come from is it really
just love or excitement or is it maybe
something else
is it maybe a mix of emotions is it
maybe the opposite sometimes when we
hate somebody we actually love them
weird but that's how perverse people can
be right
take that step back
and go what's really going on here maybe
write it down in a journal all right
you've taken one step in one day and now
the whole thing will start opening up to
you because you'll see
you'll realize in that moment that
you're continually reacting to emotions
and never analyzing them and it gets you
in trouble
you send that you send that angry email
and you go the next day what the hell
did i do that was so stupid i can't take
it back how embarrassing
day in and day out you're reacting i
want to give you the power to stop
reacting
you go
well that's right i was feeling
excitement in that moment i stepped back
i analyzed it and actually that
excitement was a feeling of envy a
feeling of insecurity it really isn't
what i thought it was
that's interesting now that gives me the
power to maybe
i don't want you to repress your
emotions because that doesn't work
emotions are very important for us for
our functioning
but awareness of them aware of where
they come from aware of your own faults
aware of the own patterns in your life
that bring trouble is extremely
important from those small steps we can
build it out something larger like i
mentioned seeing the patterns in your
life which is an extremely powerful
powerful bit of perception
because
if you know if i was fired once for
outshine the master but as i say in my
books for human beings nothing ever
happens once
there's always a pattern
if somebody if somebody does something
kind of rotten to you then they go oh
danica that wasn't me i don't know what
something came over me that's not really
who i am and you okay well maybe that's
true uh-uh that is who they are you can
bet your dog about a dollar on it
they've done that many many times before
nobody ever does anything once we're
habitual creatures
i don't mean never but usually yeah so
i have patterns that outshine the master
was a pattern of mine
and if you now can take that little
distancing thing and go from my emotions
to what are the patterns in my life who
are the bad people i've gone into
relationships with before which is all a
very common pattern you suddenly are
getting more and more power over your
phobia like man you're suddenly getting
more and more power over yourself so
that's
it's a process it's like going to the
gym it's going to take a couple years
and it'll bring you peace
it will bring you self-understanding it
will bring you better relationships in
life it'll make your workplace you'll
have less emotion and less drama which i
think we all of us need
what about the relationship between
right and wrong everyone has been in a
scenario where take your job for
instance where you were fired for you
know ultimately outshining the boss it
didn't make you wrong like you weren't
wrong necessarily and doing a great job
you learned from it you could do you
know be a little more
give a little more credit you could bend
a little more humble
but i think there's also additional
scenarios that people can think where
there's something that's truly done to
them and it's wrong
so what about that sort of dynamic of
right and wrong and still being able to
get to the emotions
well it all depends on situation i mean
um there is there is evil in this world
there are people who are malevolent and
you can't be naive and a lot of our
problems stem from our naivete we judge
people based on their appearances and
there are toxic narcissists other
they're very aggressive people
and they don't announce themselves they
don't come into your life saying hey
danica i'm i'm i'm a toxic narcissist
how are you
right now they are dressed in you know
they're the wolf dressed in sheep's
clothing right they're masters of
disguise for whatever reason so a lot of
what i'm trying to tell you is
the bad people in your life okay they're
bad you're not going to get rid of them
they are truly evil they are wrong they
are not right right when they do
something to you that's bad it's not
that it's not your fault i'm never going
to say it's your fault
but
the ability to recognize them
before they get enmeshed in your life
gives you the power to avoid them oh
yeah so
a common scenario in business because i
do a lot of consulting and business and
believe me i've been a victim of this
myself
is you're looking for a partner for your
business or you're looking for an
employee to help you
and
you hire someone thinking that they're
very charming they flatter you they're
very nice they have a good resume
and then suddenly
um several months in you see that they
have a bad character right that they're
actually
wanting to steal the company from you
that they're actually only thinking of
themselves that they're actually going
to go on social media and bad mouth left
right and center they were feeling
envious
and you go god damn what have i gotten
myself into this is nightmare i better
go find robert to consult with
well if you can recognize these people
before you get involved and i say
human beings are good at disguising
themselves but they're never perfect
so that tax toxic narcissist that became
your partner
or your or your boss or your intimate
partner
there were signs
there were signs beforehand
you just weren't paying attention
i'm not blaming you for their evil for
their wrongness i'm blaming you for
being naive and not being wary enough
and not recognizing the signs
so before you get enmeshed in their
world
let's see if you can notice
from their body language from their own
past from how they present themselves
that you might be dealing with one of
these types i don't want to make you
paranoid but i want you to be more aware
and then if it's too late if you're
already involved in the relationship and
you can't get out for whatever reason
the ability to detach yourself and say
it's their problem they're actually a
miserable person they're so narcissistic
that they have no joy in their life they
can only think of themselves we're
social animals our joy comes from
connecting to other people this person
has no joy i'm not going to get wrapped
up in the drama that they're trying to
create i'm going to actually feel sorry
for them in a way
sort of distance yourself from them and
not blame yourself but say that you know
it's it's nothing to do with me it's
their problem it's their fault
the moment you start thinking it's you
that's the problem then then you're like
then they've won it they've
they've defeated you so that's how i
would deal with dealing with truly evil
people
am i answering i am wondering if i'm
answering your question yeah yeah
absolutely you are okay and you're
giving me more questions with your
answer which is
always
always always good i kind of wanted to
have this this debate with jordan
peterson when i interviewed him about
malevolence and
it's about a co it's the concept that
you know you say there are bad people
out there and there are people that do
wrong if you point blank shoot someone
in the head when you walk up to their
car for no no apparent reason like
or nothing provoked there's a that's
wrong right i really wonder
if deep down
no matter how bad someone is
if they actually are just
someone with a deep deep wound
that they feel it's necessary to do
something bad so that they can protect
themselves so that they can repeat a
pattern that they have that was
developed from childhood whether it be
anger or rage or abuse or whatever it is
um
to uh look good to someone else maybe
doing something bad helps them look good
to someone else a group a
gang who knows
and so i just it's something i think
about a lot and i'm curious your
perspective on that because in my
exploration of human nature is that
we get programmed and we have and we
have examples in in our life proximity
that that really program us in in really
destructive ways and we're trying to
protect ourselves and survive every day
so do you really think that there are
truly bad people out there
or are they just wounded people it's
it's it's a fantastic question and if i
absolutely knew the answer i would be a
multi-billionaire i would be able to
solve all human problems because it's a
debate that goes on endlessly between
neuroscientists and education people and
sociologists
is it
genetics
is there such a thing as a bad seed
which is the word that we used to use
someone who was kind of born that way or
is it just early rearing is it just a
wound and i don't think it's either way
i don't think it's black or white i
think that it can be a mix of things
so
there was a very famous uh female
psychoanalyst in the 1950s named melanie
klein
and her thing which was so great was she
psychoanalyzed infants
and toddlers
right
and she determined that there are
children who were born who are greedier
than others
and she noticed that the way that they
would be breastfed they would be hanging
on with their teeth they would be biting
they would be breastfeeding with such
energy that was much more than another
baby
now there's no way that this could have
been had anything to do with how they
were reared because they were showing
this at two months old right it was
genetic she called them the greedy baby
right
some babies were born with a more greedy
aggressive energy
so there is a genetic component right
but we can't deny that in a lot of cases
there is a deep deep wound that comes
from early attachment is it is there
something inherent in human nature that
can make us have propensities to evil
and i say i talk i have a chapter in the
laws of human nature
on the dark side of human nature
and i try and make the argument like i
did in all the other chapters that we
all have a dark side
it is part of our nature and it comes
from a very simple reason the way that
we're reared
when we're children
two three years old
we don't
we're a complete person we're we can be
a sweet little angel and the next moment
we can pull our sister's hair and do all
sorts of mean things and beat people up
right we're not socially conditioned to
fit in perfectly we just have these
emotions and we act on them and then as
we get older we're told
robert you can't act like that you can't
pull your sister's hair you have to be
nice and sweet you have to be nice to
your teacher you have to be a good
student blah blah blah and all those
kind of
aggressive tendencies that
boys and girls girls equally have
right get pushed down know i have to be
a sweet person no i have to be angelic
no i have to fit in no i have to say the
right things people are going to judge
me if i'm not and then slowly you
develop a dark side that kind of grows
inside of you
right and becomes infesters and it comes
laid out later in life in kind of
anti-social behavior
so the strange thing is we're social
animals to the core we can't survive
without other people but on the other
hand we also have these kind of
anti-social flaws that can kind of
fester inside of us
so we need to be aware
but the thing is let's say that someone
is deeply wounded let's say you're in
you happen to be in a relationship with
one of these people and i maintain
someone pointed out to me that there's a
statistic about how many kind of
criminal minds are out there in the
human population and they said five
percent which seems a little bit high
but maybe it is right okay so they're
five percent of people who have
that genetic component and they have
maybe early um childhood issues
and they are
you know they have a criminal
anti-social mind but we would now call a
sociopath okay
so if you're involved with them the
worst thing that can happen is you
understand them so well that you let
your guard down and you don't realize
that you need distance from them right
so they have to have
limits to your empathy you have to
protect yourself from people like that
and you can't fall for the idea that you
can be the one to change them
right there are some people who can't be
reformed
you are not a social worker you can't
necessarily change these people so the
idea and i talk a lot about this in the
art of seduction
about the common scenario of the man
who's a rake who's a serial seducer of
women right
and he he's actually kind of cold in his
core he's going to dump you at some
point
and the worst thing that happens to
women in these scenarios is they go
i'm going to be the one that reforms him
he's got this bad character traitor he's
all done
he's evil
you know he's a serial seducer you know
he can't love i'm going to teach him how
to love he's going to love me
uh it's not gonna work he's got you
under his power people can change and
there are many examples of prisoners or
criminals who reform themselves and it's
an amazing beautiful story but it takes
a lot of work and it takes like people
who help them you know very deeply see
you're not as an individual to be able
to do that but you have to recognize
that there are people out there who are
kind of born that way and there's almost
nothing you can do about
what if you have someone in your life
and they're necessary they might be the
parent of your child they might be a
parent themselves your parent a brother
or sister like
maybe it's a boss even so what do you do
in a scenario where there's someone like
that that's
difficult and you know you're not going
to change them and you shouldn't try but
you have to deal with them there are
strategies where you kind of lessen them
and i don't mean to say it's impossible
to change them
some people aren't really open to change
but let's say it's a sibling right
who you're fighting with
and you've never gotten along with and
you have to see it thanksgiving and
christmas
and there's all this tension between you
and they're causing all kinds of feuds
within the family etc
the worst thing you can do is to take it
personally and get angry and and cut
yourself off from them
and and be cold to them every time you
see them and go
damn that person i just don't want
anything to do with it because you're
just simply enforcing their own notion
their own wound that nobody likes them
right
you're making the situation worse
because you're automatically looking at
them as somebody that has a problem and
that they're internalizing that you see
them that way therefore they're going to
act that way
so try a different strategy at
thanksgiving dinner
and i tell people this kind of
contradicting my last answer but it's
okay for me to contradict myself so you
see them at thanksgiving and i tell
people
try and do this following exercise when
you look at them
instead of your first thought is
i don't like i've got to keep away that
they're ugly i don't like them think the
opposite go let's just give that person
a name gary
gary's a good person he's a nice person
he was wounded in childhood he's
actually got a kind heart there's
something good about him
just don't even say it
just think it
and you'd be surprised how the thinking
is communicating to the other person
non-verbally whereas the thought god
damn i can't stand gary he drives me
crazy they're picking it up they're
picking it up right because we feed off
nonverbal communication
yeah and then you start treating them
differently you start trying to
what i call entering their spirit you
try and reflect and mirror them they
have these certain interests that
actually don't interest you at all they
love like gory horror films which you
can't stand you kind of go out of your
way to to sort of say yeah i kind of
like that film or to enter their world
because when you have a deep wound like
that
what happens is people sense it and they
treat you differently and they they kind
of keep you at a distance and suddenly
you develop this crust around you where
you don't let anybody in because nobody
wants to talk to you really about
anything that matters you want to break
that crust down you want to enter their
world into their spirit and begin to
make let them relax a little bit around
you
so
feeling that and going through those
motions
you're not going to change this person
and make them you know the ideal that
you would want for a sibling but maybe
you can break the ice and maybe some
communication can open up and maybe that
family dynamic will begin to change
and they're brilliant family therapists
who have operated on this level you know
have done some miraculous things with
the
black sheep of the family that's exactly
what i was thinking about is it feels
like i'm reading uh the body keeps the
score so i'm reading about a therapist
for a great book therapist perspective
as as he deals with
loads of different kinds of trauma and
the most recent story was just about
someone going ape [ __ ] in the office at
first and it was like they were looking
for a repeat they were looking for
someone to respond to them and probably
say get out right or i'm ready
and the therapist just sits there you
know he just sits there and he allows
this
tantrum to happen and then there's a
trust that develops because you are
looking past the actions to the human
underneath it and so it feels like
almost like a therapist-like approach
where you just you allow them to be
you allow them their their you allow
them to be who they want to be and you
respect that you know it's coming from a
sad place and you have more empathy as
opposed to anger with them um
yeah great book but i also was thinking
about the fact that you were talking
about non-verbal in my opinion i think
this is a direction culturally we need
to go is to continue to
be able to get to ourselves to awareness
to our feelings and to our intuition and
so i was thinking about you know the
story of the baby and you know being a
greedy baby at just you know a few
months old
but from my researching especially from
bruce lipton that the human subconscious
is programmed from
they say the last trimester of pregnancy
on
so
it feels to me like there's a
possibility and i don't i don't hear you
arguing i hear you saying you're not
sure if there's true malevolence or not
um but it seems like there are so
supposedly some studies that that would
sort of say people are genetically
different but i wonder if instead of it
being sort of a participation in in
actions it's an energetic exchange that
creates the monster the greedy baby
you mean you mean the baby in the last
trimester was picking up something from
the mother
that's an interesting theory i've never
heard anything about i don't know how
anybody could prove it but i'm sure
there is
because they've done studies where
they um
the mother plays certain classical music
or certain music for the baby and it in
you know in the last trimester it has a
definite effect on them so i'm sure
there's some some validity to that yeah
but i mean still i still would maintain
that there's probably a genetic
component that that is underlying it
even then
that even even prior to that trimester
there are things that are that are going
on that are underneath there that we'll
never ever really know i mean
if you study human nature and psychology
like the people you've referred to that
the great book
i'm not on their level but i've studied
it for many years you develop a bit of
humility because humans are so complex
complicated and if you spend one minute
analyzing yourself and analyzing the
degrees of emotions you can have in
three minute period and how your mind
will go from this that and the other you
begin to appreciate the incredible
complexity of the human being which is
why i'm very skeptical about things like
artificial intelligence because i don't
think you can ever replicate the
incredible complexity of the human brain
and the incredible complexity of our
nature how we can feel things and
understand things not through
necessarily rational um appreciation but
through intuition
intuition is an incredible part of our
knowledge and our ability to get
anything done you can't probe that into
machine
so
i don't have the answers about this
genetic component or not i'm i sort of
am humbled by the fact that
there's so many mysteries about human
nature that i don't think we'll ever
understand because we're this marvelous
creation
the human brain as i'm discussing in my
next book
is the most complex organism in the
entire universe the number of cells the
number of neuronal connections in the
brain far surpassed the number of
of stars in in the universe of the uh
you know it's just it's an incredible
thing about our brains are just
unbelievable so i don't think i can ever
really completely understand it and i
come to the subject with a degree of
i'm trying to understand it and there's
still mysteries that i'll never be able
to solve i think that's part of the
human experience that makes it
interesting yet frustrating and so it
kind of leads me into asking about this
book because i think i heard you it's
based on basically the big bang right
and sort of the trajectory
after that and is that is this correct
and like trying to understand and
explore people's limited thinking
um is that is that right is that the
book you're alluding to
my new book when i'm writing right now
yeah yeah i mean i have parts of it in
in the daily laws in the month of
december well basically it's a book i
call it about the sublime
and i have this idea about human nature
that i've had for many many years and
the idea is that i kind of compare it to
a circle
that human beings naturally live inside
of a circle and that circle is this is
what you're supposed to think in your
culture this is how you're supposed to
behave there are rules they're
conventions you're not supposed to think
these kinds of thoughts you're supposed
to think these other ones
and that circle
existed in ancient egypt it didn't have
the same
things that we have but it still was a
limitation you're not supposed to think
this an ancient egypt you're supposed to
behave this way it's changed the content
but that physical reality is the same
the moment you praise limits for the
human being they're fascinated by what
lies beyond it's part of our nature we
like what's supposedly transgressive
we're not supposed to go there we want
to go there you've ever had a
two-year-old you say no don't do that or
a cat don't go there that's where they
go the moment your back is turned right
not to say the cats have the same nature
as humans but they kind of do
um anyway so
i'm saying that what lies outside that
circle is what i call the realm of the
sublime and i want people to begin to
think outside of that to expand their
minds to expand their consciousness to
not live in the sort of narrow little
world of your smartphone of what people
are telling you how you're supposed to
think and feel but to expand your mind
to other possibilities of looking at the
world
so i explained in the first chapter
about the big bang and the cosmos
and and the story of
the evolution of our universe
and first of all if you explore it
through through physics it's a lot of
science
it's the most insanely amazing beautiful
story that you could ever put together
it's so unlikely the way things ended up
becoming the way they are to see how
stars evolved to see how our galaxy
evolved how our solar system how the sun
was born and then how the earth broke
off from this kind of big block of of
rock and that how
our earth collided with another planet
some
i don't know how many billion four
billion early on in our history and that
collision created the moon
and you know
it's it's an unbelievably beautiful
story and it'll make you realize that
you're thinking here of your own
day-to-day affairs you're only thinking
about instagram etc
and yet this is this thing's been going
on for 13 billion years it'll blow your
mind it'll expand your thinking it'll
make you appreciate
just being alive it'll make you
appreciate that we have a sun that we
have light that we have water
it'll change your thinking to expand
your mind outside this narrow circle
that we inhabit i have each chapter is
about that
the chapter about evolution about how
humans evolve which is an insane another
insane story i have a chapter about
ancient history and how
old religions had a different way of
looking at the human being that are
incredibly interesting beautiful i'm
writing a chapter now on childhood and
how the world of children and their
minds are very different from adults and
how it's extremely exciting how you once
used to think when you were three years
old you have no access to how you were
thinking when you were three because you
it's so different from how you think now
you're not even aware of it but you
lived in this really surreal
amazing world where your senses were so
open
the child's brain is completely very
different from the adult brain and it's
kind of fascinating to study so i go
into that and how you can access your
childhood more easily as you're as an
adult so that's each you know animals
how insane animals are and how their
consciousness is actually quite related
to our own on and on and on so that's
sort of the book that i'm working on
like what are the spinning thoughts that
you've had for some time about this idea
of how unlikely it is that we're here
how
you know miraculous the whole experience
is or maybe a better question is what do
you hope
to find
in writing the book that will then be
the message that you hope people get
from reading it well i'll tell you it's
it's weird thing it's a little bit
personal but i'll go into it originally
i intended the book as kind of a therapy
for you to kind of get you outside of
your yourself because we get so
self-absorbed that it makes us it turns
us off from the wonders of our world i
know it sounds like a bit of a cliche
but it is an incredibly wondrous world
that is around us and we tend to get as
we get older our circle gets narrower
and narrower and narrower so i thought
of it as a book of therapy
but honestly what happened is um
about three years ago i had a stroke
and
my life suddenly hit a wall
um i was very athletic i mean i'm not
i'm not an athlete but i was i swam
every almost every day
mountain biked
hiked et cetera et cetera that was my
whole that was really
an integral part of who i am
all that taken away right i can't swim
anymore i can't really i can't hike i
can barely walk walk with struggles
i have a special bike that i use which
is my salvation but basically that was
taken away from me
so i have to live in my house in my
office
and write a book and i have no outlets
my outlets used to be
walking and thinking it used to be going
in my backyard and observing things
all this kind of i can't do that
so i have to find other ways
of creating my own therapy and healing
my own wounds from this injury and so
the book has become that
so
when it's four o'clock
and it's time for me to start writing
which is often when i start it's like
wow it's the highest point of my day i
get to get my head out of my my pity and
my worries and all that and get into
these subjects and immerse my head in
the cosmos in dinosaurs in all this
incredible history and it's it's like
therapy for myself and so a lot of
people are in that situation in life
right
they don't have a lot of money they're
not traveling to exotic locations they
have a job they don't necessarily like
i want to bring this books to the that
anybody it's going to have that kind of
therapeutic effect where you're you may
not be trapped by an injury like i am
but you're trapped by something else and
i want you you can heal some of that
through your mind through how you think
and my i have an idea in the book that
your mind either kind of contracts or
expands to what you think about
right you control that if you're only
thinking about your instagram account or
something like that that mind will
narrow narrow and narrow but if you're
thinking about all these other issues
that i'm talking about about evolution
about what it means to be human about
our relationship to animals about nature
about the brain itself
your mind is expanding and it's it will
have a i hope a therapeutic impact on
you i don't know why i feel like i want
to ask you this and it might be off base
but it just something just came to mind
and there's a lot of conversation around
it and i'm curious if this is something
that you've done or thought about and
maybe the power of it is
plant medicine i mean
oh
psilocybin you know just based on the
fact that you know it takes you to
another place
i'm completely open to that um i mean
when i was in college you know and i
went to college not college not far from
where you were i went in wisconsin
i went to uw
um
i was heavily into drugs that's madison
right madison yeah party town party
school i think it was like number one
party school many years in a row
yeah well i'm older this was like in the
in this late 70s that i was there
i started
yeah
i don't think i can take credit for what
goes on on state street in madison but
all right i'll try um
i didn't start but there was also a lot
of like political activism it was kind
of you know a left-wing town as madison
still sort of is
it's just it's beautiful i love madison
coming from california
i fell in love with it it's beautiful
and i loved cross-country skiing to
class
on and on and on but um so i did lsd i
did mushrooms i did peyote which is what
mescaline comes from i did a lot of pot
i did hash
you name it i took it right i even did
shoe polish at one point um
it did start it
i don't recommend i should take that
back i don't recommend that for anyone
um
anyway uh and it's it's a very important
part of of human nature because the
history of people taking plant
substances
goes back thousands of years even
animals are known to do that it's
definitely an important role in that
i don't know at my advanced age now
since i passed the age of 60
how well i can handle lsd
with the damage i had to my brain
that i've had already you know because i
because when you have a stroke
oxygen is cut from your brain for
several minutes and that's what causes
the damage so i have lasting brain
damage
and it's fortunate that i can write a
book although we'll see how the book
comes out but um
i don't know if i should be mixing
taking a risk with that and ryan would
say no robert don't do it part of me
does want to do it part of me at least
wants to take something safe like
mushrooms i'm not going to do ayahuasca
because i'm a little bit worried about
that you know i think i would kind of
something some some demon would be
dredged up that i would never kill i've
never been in uw days
yeah exactly
like robert this is why you're here
yeah
you're from beloit i am i was born in
beloit wisconsin and i grew up just over
the border in roscoe illinois
oh oh did you go to madison when you
were younger
i actually didn't go to college at all i
actually didn't even graduate high
school i moved did you even visit did
you even oh yeah yeah definitely been to
madison yeah um i've been there quite a
few times um
yeah it's a really cool town um
you went to england you said i did when
i was 16 i moved to england for racing
so
that was kind of my college um i yeah i
left halfway through junior year and got
my ged and
it's like i remember my boss at the my
first real racing boss bobby ray hall's
name um who won the indy 500 and
and he said he said this statement the
youth is wasted on the young and i it's
never i've
never forgotten that because now i like
i mean if you saw like all of my notes
and my research and i mean i just
consume information
willingly and aggressively
and um not only that but of course
physically and function wise there's so
much
so much malleability and stamina when
you're young and the youth is wasted on
the young because now i find myself
wanting to learn a whole bunch of stuff
and
you know when you're a teenager or a kid
and you have to sit in the same spot in
class and the rug or you have to raise
your hand to go to the bathroom or
you're learning about something stupid
and saw in you know math that you'll
never use in your life it's like this is
your exploration time and you get stuck
in a room so um yeah i left and i moved
to england and started racing or well i
didn't start racing i went to cars
but they drive on the other side of the
road yeah they did how was that
i lived in london i lived in london and
i was i was an intern at a television
company and they once tried to get me to
drive their car in london i couldn't do
it it was too nerve-wracking i thought i
was hitting the curb every i was hitting
past pedestrians in the curb
london
place to start off um how did you manage
i mean i drove as soon as i could which
was 17 i think is the driving age over
there yeah okay i had i drove as soon as
i could which wasn't when i first got
there and um the race cars though are
not like that so the race cars i drove
were were single seaters so it's just
one little cockpit and the shifter was
with the right hand and so that was all
very normal but the but the car
uh actually yeah the car would have been
yeah left hand shifting sitting on the
right side and it just came naturally
you know like you said kids pick up tons
of stuff i mean i'm a teenager and you
just do it and um you know i also also i
was i'm a race car driver so um it came
pretty naturally to drive for me but
london's not the place that you want to
go test the waters driving a car no no
no no
always look forward because there's so
much happening around you that if you
take a second to look in the rearview
mirror you're going to hit something
because something's happening
i know i didn't i only drove once and
that was it and then they just put me on
a motorbike to do the deliveries and
that was fun that was fun
nearly got killed a dozen times but i
enjoyed that yeah i was gonna say a bike
sounds far more dangerous there's not a
lot protecting you there
talking about your stroke and the change
of
life that you've had and i'm sure that i
just can't imagine actually i can't
empathize i don't i don't know how that
would be but i can under i can
fathom that it's
frustrating sad
um
what is your relationship with amura
fatih
meaning the love of fate right and so
is this something does it do are you
feeling do you feel really tested with
that very concept
that that was the ultimate test because
my first reaction was
to hate fate
right i'm trying to think of what that
would be that would be od fati i think
um
odin fati you know just like damn why me
my whole life
you know and probably what caused my
stroke was an inadvertent beasting in my
neck
you know that um created a big flare-up
and cholesterol and all this stuff and
then and the
blood clot occurred right where the
beast hit me if i had walked five
minutes earlier
or that that bee had missed me
wouldn't happen you know how do you deal
with something like that right so
of course initially there was no amor
fati but i don't want to be a hypocrite
and i and i and i take seriously my own
ideas and i want to live it and slowly
it became clear to me
that this is my reality and maybe it did
happen for a reason because a morphati
is
even though things maybe don't happen
for a reason it's best to kind of think
of them that way right it's easier to
process
exactly so
when the stroke happened
i was driving here in los angeles and my
wife was on the other was with the
passenger
she saw and she forced me off the road
immediately called 9-1-1 and i was
unconscious
i could easily have been driving by
myself like i alpha they am or swimming
or something i'd be dead right now or
i'd have severe brain damage and the
most important thing in my life is
thinking
so fortunately
my left side of my body was rendered
paralyzed but my brain was is intact i
can write another book
i i can love fate for that i can love
the fact that i'm alive i had a slight
near-death experience
slide in that i had some you know some
visions and stuff i do want to hear
about that
okay
well it you know and that kind of gave
me an intense um
appreciation of what it means to be
alive right something we completely take
for granted when you feel
like i felt like my body was being
drained of life that so that what
happened in the near-death experience
was i had this sensation that my bones
were kind of melting that i was losing
life through my skeleton through my
bones and it was all coming out of me
and my skeleton my bones were getting
softer and softer and softer
and then
and then i had this idea and still to
this day
less now because it's three years now i
still have that sensation of something a
little bit soft in my in my bones i'm so
i can't really explain it and i had a
vision
while i was in my coma of kind of being
above ground and looking down and seeing
my mother and my wife talking
and then i was kind of telling myself
it's all right everything's fine they're
okay the world goes on it's okay
you know it's okay to leave this world
and so um you know other people have
much stronger
near-death experience is probably
because
my coma wasn't as deep and long as other
people's
but it makes you think about life in a
whole different way
i don't think of
of of the world the way i did beforehand
or about people who've never had it
think so it's a special thing that
happened
it's a mark of cain it's like it
distinguishes me
i'm one of the few people who kind of
felt death there are people around the
world
it was a privilege
i mean not really but it's how i think
about it you know it kind of something
gives me access to a way of thinking
it's going to help me write my new book
because i'm not writing about the
sublime as if it's an intellectual
exercise i lived it
i lived that i i felt that i felt the
breath of it on me so i'm not just
writing about it in this kind of
intellectual way it's visceral it's
inside of me
so that's how i go through a morphati i
find the things i can glean from that
experience that are immensely positive
and there are other ones such as
appreciating
life itself such as you know forcing me
to make this the one project that's
going to save my brain and make a really
great book to help other people
who feel the same way
you know on and on so that's how i've
been able to activate
more fatty in kind of bad circumstances
that you changed your perception and you
trained yourself to change your
perception it sounds like
yeah i mean the other thing is um
you realize so i'm kind of a
type a person
i always was a i have an injury i hurt
my back i'm going to push through i'm
going to exercise i'm going to swim my
way out of this
you can't do that with a stroke
you know you can't no am i i do a lot of
therapy but no amount of exercise is
going to bring your left leg back to
where it was you have to be patient
so i've had to develop i've seen flaws
in myself to the pre-stroke person
and now i'm learning that i have to
become someone who's much more patient
and much more forgiving of my body and
who i am and not so be hard on myself so
it's taught me a lot of things about my
own limitations and my own kind of flaws
what do you think as far as coming into
this
well i don't know maybe the first
question is do you believe in
reincarnation because it's going to my
question is going to
lead into incarnating and making choices
before you come in so maybe the first
question is do you even believe in that
well i'm kind of a
hardcore practical
realistic person you know um
uh and
so i i i don't i've never
i don't necessarily don't believe in it
but it's never been part of my
experience i've never
i have i can tell you one thing that is
weird
so i'm not close to the idea but um my
major
in in college at madison
was classics ancient greek and latin
and i had this connection to ancient
greece
which was uncanny
like i could pick up the language faster
than other people
and to this day
i had this sort of intuition about how
they thought
you know like i'll be writing about
athena in one of my chapters and i'm not
doing the research i'm just writing off
the top of my head and then i go and do
the research and realize you were right
that was exactly the truth
i had this weird connection to ancient
greece where i kind of have an intuitive
connection to it
who knows where that comes from it's
weird that's very interesting it feels
it feels uncanny to me
i've never had the feeling that i was
alexander the great incarnated or
anything like that i wish
but um so i'm not close to the idea
there's something weird about those kind
of feelings and there's something weird
about the past somebody who studies a
lot of history and understands that we
are products of generations that precede
us
and often i have the feeling of the
thought
um because i also have like very
powerful connections
to certain periods of history
so for instance
don't ask me why
but 17th century france seems to be a
period that i connect very deeply wow
was i walking around in a powdered wig
you know
on stilts you know you know wearing
strange costumes maybe i was yeah um
but i because i read so much history i
believe that we are products of the past
and it lives inside of us
so what happened 300 years ago is living
inside of me right now
so i'm not close to the idea i just and
maybe as i get older i'll have
some kind of epiphany about it and maybe
i will come to that opinion like i'm
agnostic with it i haven't closed my
mind i'm open to it but i'm not i'm not
yet a believer
okay that's fair i think that's still i
think that's still good enough to ask
the question um thank you and thank you
and sharing for that that's i i agree
there are certain aspects and times and
cultures that resonate with me deeply
too so you're not alone and you also
aren't alone in your reaction and how
you're like don't ask me how i don't
know like it feels silly because there's
literally no obvious connection and so
it sounds kind of just like
this deep imagination um and maybe some
some [ __ ] but it also
but it also feels kind of true
and so what were the periods of history
that you had a connection to um
egyptian um
i yeah i'm not going to give you my
self-inflated narcissistic perspective
on what i think i was in those times um
but i've deep connection to those and i
went to egypt last year at the beginning
of the year finally but it's one of
those ironic places that i wanted to go
from like my late teens for no reason
like there's no good reason um so i felt
very connected to that and in fact i i
leave on saturday from mexico again
where are you going in mexico yucatan
i'm going yeah i've gone i've gone to
tulum many times me too yeah what do you
think
oh i love tulum it's it's a little bit
weird now i hear there's been crime and
everything
but there's there's a hotel i can't
remember we stay out at the end of the
beach it's absolutely wonderful
oh yeah that's the first place i ever
stayed there it's beautiful yeah yeah oh
tulum is wonderful i'm so jealous well
have you been to the maya the to the
ruins there the uh
i did not go i ironically in all like
six times that i've been i haven't i've
been to the coba
and then this trip is actually a retreat
trip with nasim haramin who's a
scientist
and we're going to chichen itza and
a couple other places as well as like a
bunch of bunch of lectures on quantum
physics which is another passion of mine
is the curiosity about human you know
the nature of reality um but we're
saying and i think apply to carmen this
time it's just a little further north
but um
but i i feel very connected to that
culture for some reason and i and i
don't know why either um and then viking
i feel like i was literally on the front
of a boat like
telling the guys what to do
i was in have you ever been to norway
no
oh oslo
um they have a viking museum there i'm
norwegian i'm my mom's 100 norwegian i'm
halfway
well you're from wisconsin what would
one expect they have a viking museum in
oslo
you have to go i mean it's it's your
it's your blood it's your heritage um
and they have like
ships
and and and all kinds of other stuff oh
the ships are so beautiful
they're like incredible works of art you
know
um so the question being
now that we've covered that maybe
there's some sort of intuition on other
cycles
is that
there's another theory that we choose
our life we choose our parents we choose
our challenges we choose these things
we're sort of like also like a
evolutionary soul right so um we're
continuing to pick up where we left off
in these cycles of life and we we we
come to learn the lessons and expand and
that source energy itself is this
fractioned off energy that wants to know
itself and so it's doing that through
all of us and every other thing in the
universe to know itself and so and to
expand right and so it's expansion and
learning so right what other better way
to learn than to come in to a life again
and choose the challenges choose things
that are going to create growth
and so
i'm just curious if you
what you know just how that falls into
your
you know experience now and do you feel
like that resonates and and and do you
feel like that you've ultimately
do you feel like you're better
for the experience of having a stroke or
not
well i i am better i mean um
you know who knows what would have
happened if i hadn't had one because i
was heading down to the path i'd
probably be dead by now so there's that
way of looking why yeah because i worked
so hard
when i finished the laws of human nature
my stroke occurred three months later i
had driven myself to the near death i
was so exhausted and so i stressed i
just destroyed my body literally
shredded to pieces by thinking and
working too hard
so i was headed down the wrong path
and life
was kind of teaching me a different way
to go
but if you know there are ways of
looking at this question to kind of give
it a more wider perspective i love that
is that is if
if you look at
the history of the universe and i'm i'm
a neophyte of this i'm not a physicist
and you're going to have some very
interesting discussions done in yucatan
about this but if you study um
starting with the big bang and this is
my first chapter i kind of take you on a
journey through everything leading to
the present moment in our cosmos
you studied the big bang itself
and then
um how
stars kind of the first star
came to being in in this universe of
incredible heat
right because the big bang generated
insane amounts of heat and was expanding
at this rapid pace
the first star that came and what it
came out of and then it exploded that
there was the first star and that how
that star exploded and created other
stars and then how galaxies were formed
etc
leading up to our sun
and then to planet earth being exactly
the right distance from the sun for life
to evolve and water arriving here
probably from comets and asteroids
right
and certain chemicals
um arriving in minerals arriving from
outer space that gave the
the potential for life on earth
and how
it started life started like 3 billion
some years ago
and was an experiment and it could have
easily not continued it almost ended
and then on and on and on through what
they call bottlenecks of evolution where
if this hadn't happened if this had
moved one direction this way
um vertebrates wouldn't have evolved
multicellular creatures wouldn't have
evolved
if that comet hadn't hit earth in the
yucatan dinosaurs would still be roaming
the planet if you stretch that all the
way to humans
you begin to have this weird sensation
that
it almost seems like it was meant to
happen for human beings to evolve for
consciousness to evolve so that we could
piece together this entire story
i mean the piecing together of that
story is one of the greatest things ever
i often lose faith in humanity for
various reasons but when i look at what
people have been able to do in things
like physics to understand
like the big bang itself
it gives you the feeling that maybe it
happened for a reason that this was the
word it was all heading towards was the
creation of consciousness maybe there's
the same obviously it probably is on
other planets and they could say the
same thing
but that it gives you a sense that maybe
it was meant to happen that way because
it's so weird
it's so unlikely that that asteroid hit
planet earth 65 billion years ago over
there 67 billion years ago and wiped out
the dinosaurs and created a space for
mammals to evolve it's so unlikely that
you know how could that have been maybe
there is something behind it
yeah i think that i think that answers
it in a beautiful way that is hopeful
i guess it makes me follow up with one
more question in this sort of
outer space realm
okay
i love outer space questions good me too
uh the
assistance or intervention of
extraterrestrial
in our existence as humans in your
research of the planet itself and
evolution and then humans
do you feel like that there has been
intervention
or do you feel like they were part of
the reason why we made it
i don't know once again i'm agnostic i
remember i had a brother-in-law years
ago who thought that he
that there were extraterrestrials that
had intermingled him that he was
descended from them
you know and he was uh
an intellect he was like a professor
so and i thought wow that's an
interesting thought
um and then if you read about the dogons
in africa
they're an amazing
story because they have drawings
in their caves and cetera
petroglyphs that seem there seem to be
very accurate depictions of something
coming from outer space right and it's
very uncanny their knowledge
of the universe they almost i have a
book called i think it's called the
science of the dogons i don't remember
which i can send you the link later on
where um
they have theories about the origin of
the universe that are very uncannily
similar to the big bang
they had ideas about energy
and about um quantum physics i forget
which which idea that were just
remarkably prescient and ahead of their
time
where did that come from
i don't know
but there's another theory because i'm
going into the alien idea obviously from
my book
which is that
because
life was so unlikely to begin on planet
earth
that we had to go through
hundreds of these little bottlenecks to
arrive at this particular moment in time
right
and that is by a fluke that neanderthals
didn't survive instead of homo sapiens
etc what would that look like etc
there's all these other kind of things
so
we had to go through all of these
weird little hoops to get to where we
are now
and the odds against it are so huge
it's possible that it never that there's
nothing ever like that in all the
universe there are people who believe
that life is so unlikely the way it came
about
that it's possible like planets like
mars
where they maybe had life
originally like here there was water and
then because of that one little thing
that went wrong like it could have here
the planet completely dried out and
became a frozen planet or venus became a
completely hot planet and life was
destroyed
that that is the more likely scenario
throughout the universe
and the other thing is
to travel immense distances
like light years to get from outer space
to planet earth
requires
very lengthy periods of time so we're
talking about people people would have
to be living thousands of years to be
able to reach the end of their journey
unless they had developed a form of
speed that is beyond our comprehension
so if there was alien life
it's probably silicon it's probably
robotic life
sure they created robots to travel
thousands of years and arrive at planet
earth and mix with the dogons and teach
them this or that the other
that's a possibility but the other thing
is
maybe it never happened and maybe we're
alone
you know which is a scary thought
um and and that makes it even scary if
we're going to mess it all up and
destroy our planet the one the one
experiment in the universe
people argue geophysicists
astrophysicists go back and forth on
this
and they no one i don't know if they'll
ever solve it some believe
that it's highly unlikely there wouldn't
be conscious life in the universe and
others believe that it's highly unlikely
that there would be
so i'm not committing myself i know that
seems kind of cowardly
but um moments i feel like there has to
be something out there there has to be
some kind of
extraterrestrial life form but the
scientist in me wonders is that even
really possible given all that i've been
learning so
yeah not a very satisfactory answer i'm
sorry delica i think it's but i think
that part of your part of your gift is
this exploration and also you know
you're obviously highly intellectual and
so
you know it takes some research before
you commit to something because that's
part of that's part of intellect is
doing your research and you know that i
mean i'm kind of i'm asking about what
you're writing about on some level maybe
you won't write about aliens maybe you
won't write about extraterrestrial
intervention but it's in that vein and
this is where you're going right now
like you're in this place so it's just
kind of exploratory and i'm just kind of
poking and having fun and and and asking
for your perspectives on some
wide wide ideas
well the world is so weird and so
mysterious it's so far beyond our
knowledge that it's extremely possible
that what you're talking about has
happened so i never like to close my
mind to these possibilities because our
minds are limited human brain is limited
and they're things that exist that we're
never going to be aware of like
what's beyond the edge of our universe
this is a thought that the devils
physicists and philosophers you know or
what was there before the big bang try
and think about that one
i these are the things that plagued me
when i was a kid that made me know that
i was curious about the universe because
i would think to myself as i looked up
at the stars as a kid and i would go it
goes for infinity and what's at the end
of infinity there's nothing
it's not there's there's got to be but
there's got to be an end and if there's
an end what does it look like and then
yeah so you know it's kind of like
concepts and ideas and exploring them we
continue to unpack and unravel and at
the rate that you know we as humans are
expanding i think neil degrasse tyson
said that you know it's a circle of
information and every time you ask a
question outside the circle the entire
circle gets bigger so there's infinitely
more questions which is ironically kind
of the universe that is expanding
accelerated rate so like it seems as
though it's almost similar in nature
we live in a fractal universe and it's
very interesting that's for sure and i
love exploring these these ideas with
you
and
i had a lot of fun today thank you for
me too me too i had a very good a great
time thanks everybody for listening to
the pretty intense podcast today i hope
you enjoyed it if you like what you
heard today and you want to hear more
please click on the subscribe button